bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de parcours sup alors par pur sucre vous
le savez sans doute c'est la procédure
d'affectation des élèves de terminale
aux formations de l'enseignement
supérieur les universités les bts les
classes prépas et c'est l'idée de cette
vidéo ça n'est pas de vous donner des
conseils d'orientation mais plutôt
d'évoquer les mathématiques qui se cache
derrière parcours sup et notamment les
fameux algorithme d'affectation qui ont
été beaucoup décrié et critiqué comme il
me semble que cette peur des algorithmes
relève largement d'une méconnaissance de
ce qu'ils font vraiment et de comment
ils le font aujourd'hui on va essayer de
faire un peu la lumière sur ce sujet
controversé
la question que parcours sud s'efforcent
de résoudre est assez ancienne et très
naturelle on a un certain nombre de
futurs étudiants et un certain nombre de
formations de l'enseignement supérieur
et on doit affecter les étudiants aux
formations
évidemment on va pas faire ça au pif
puisque d'un côté les étudiants ont des
souhaits d'orientation des formations
qu'ils préfèrent et d'autres qui ne les
intéressent pas et de l'autre côté les
formations elles ont des places limitées
et doivent donc appliquer des critères
de sélection pour choisir les étudiants
qu'elles vont admettre
avant 2009 en france il s'agissait d'un
processus décentraliser les étudiants
prenez contact individuellement avec les
formations qui les intéressait il
envoyait un dossier et les formations
leur disais oui ou non les étudiants
devaient ensuite choisir parmi les
formations auxquelles il avait été admis
et donner une réponse
ensuite les formations avaient la
possibilité de rappeler des candidats
qu'elle avait mis provisoirement sur
l'île d'attentes et ainsi de suite
cette procédure décentralisée était
franchement inefficace ça prenait un
temps fou ou faisaient des aller retour
de courrier entre les formations et les
étudiants et c'était un casse tête pour
tout le monde
d'un côté les formations devaient
essayer d'anticiper la taille a donné
aux listes d'admission et au lisa tente
pour éviter d'être en surnombre ou au
contraire en sous-nombre à la fin et de
l'autre les étudiants devaient parfois
attendre des mois avant d'avoir une
réponse ce qui était stressant et peser
lourd notamment sur ce qui devait être
ouvert logement et à la fin le résultat
de l'affectation était loin d'être le
meilleur possible
cette situation n'était évidemment pas
spécifique de l'enseignement supérieur
français et par exemple dès les années
50 les faits
mation médical aux etats-unis se sont
dits qu'il fallait trouver un meilleur
système
ils ont alors imaginé une procédure
groupe est centralisée permettant
d'affecter les internes en médecine aux
différents hôpitaux du pays en fonction
des choix des uns et des autres la
première version de cette procédure
était très simple c'est une sorte
d'affectation au fur et à mesure dans
cette procédure tous les étudiants
commencent par classe et toutes les
formations qu'ils visent par ordre de
préférence
on prend ensuite le premier choix de
chaque étudiant on le soumet aux
formations considérées qui décide alors
pour chaque étudiant
si elle accepte ou pas pour ceux qui ont
été refusées on passe alors à leur
deuxième choix et on recommence prenons
un exemple concret imaginons trois
étudiants alice bob et charlie et trois
formations la fac de lettres celles
d'économie et celle de science on va
supposer pour simplifier que chaque
formation n'a qu'une seule place les
étudiants classe les formations par
ordre de préférence
disons qu alice préfère l'écho aux
lettres et classe la fac de sciences en
dernier bob lui préfère les lettres à
l'économie et les sciences en dernier
aussi et charlie pareil que bob en face
de ça les formations elles aussi ont des
préférences
c'est à dire que si elles reçoivent
simultanément plusieurs candidatures et
bien elles devront choisir leur candidat
préféré
on va dire que la fac de lettres
préférerait prendre à l'iss puis charlie
et en dernier bob celles d'économie son
classement de préférence c'est bob alice
charlie et la fan de science charlie
alice puis bob simulant maintenant la
procédure d'affectation les candidats
postulent d'abord chacun à leur premier
choix donc alice en écho bob et charlie
en lettres la fac d'économie n'a reçu
qu'une seule candidature celle d'alice
et donc l'acceptent la fac de lettres
elle a le choix entre bob et charlie qui
il n'y a qu'une place
on l'a dit et elle choisit donc de
prendre son préféré parmi les 2
c'est-à-dire charlie à ce stade à la fin
du premier tour
bob s'est fait refuser et il est donc
sans affectation on fait alors un
deuxième tour où on regarde son deuxième
choix l'économie sauf qu'il n'ya plus de
place en écho puisque alice a déjà été
accepté donc gober contraint de postuler
à son troisième choix la fac de sciences
qui n'a reçu à ce stade que cette
candidature est donc l'acceptent à la
fin avec cette méthode
alice va en économie charlie en lettres
bob se retrouve en science cette
procédure d'affectation elle peut
paraître assez raisonnable notamment
parce qu'elle vise à satisfaire au
maximum les premiers choix ce que les
étudiants ont mis tout en haut de leur
liste
mais si on regarde dans le détail elle a
quand même quelques défauts regardez
baume à la fin ils se retrouvent en
sciences qui était son dernier choix
mais au tour d'avant il s'est fait
refuser en écho parce que la fac d'éco
avait déjà accepté à l'iss sauf que la
fac d'éco si on regarde son classement
initial
eh bien elle aurait préféré baume à
alice dont bob un peu de quoi elle
vénère il s'est fait piquer la place en
fac d'éco par quelqu'un qui était moins
bien classé que lui par cette formation
il peut considérer qu'il s'est fait
avoir par la procédure
on dit que cette procédure n'est pas
équitable c'est son premier défaut et
donc ce qu'aurait dû faire bob pour
éviter cette situation c'est de la jouer
tactique dès le départ plutôt que la fac
de lettres même si c'est vraiment
sincèrement ce qu'il aurait préféré
faire il aurait dû mettre écho en
premier dans son classement avec ça il
aurait été admis au premier tour en écho
ce qui aurait été mieux du moins à ses
yeux que de finir en sciences pour
optimiser ses chances bob aurait dû
bricoler son classement initial est en
quelque sorte mentir sur ses préférences
réel en faisant une croix sur la fac de
lettres sans savoir vraiment s'il avait
une chance d'être pris ou pas mais du
coup si bob avait fait ça dès le départ
en refaisant la procédure vous pouvez
vous convaincre que c'est alice qui
aurait fini en sciences et qu'à son tour
elle aurait aussi pu trouver cela
inéquitable et avoir des regrets de ne
pas avoir joué tactique
par exemple en classant les lettres en
premier bref cette procédure
d'affectation n'est finalement pas très
satisfaisante car les étudiants sont
incités à faire des calculs tactiques
pour essayer d'améliorer leur sort
plutôt que d'être honnête et sincère sur
leurs préférences
quand une situation de ce type se
produit on dit que la procédure est
manipulable
les étudiants peuvent tenter d'avoir
mieux en ne la joue pas sincèrement ce
qui a tendance à favoriser ceux qui ont
les meilleures infos sur le
fonctionnement du système aux dépens des
autres sachant plus que tout ça est
forcément basée sur des paris et des
sacrifices et que donc ça génère du
stress et peut être des regrets
vous voyez donc que cette première
procédure d'affectation de centraliser
elle peut paraître au premier abord
intéressante mais elle se révèle à la
fois inéquitable et manipulable la
question évidemment c s
on peut faire mieux c'est à dire est ce
qu'on peut trouver une procédure qui
soit à la fois équitable juste et qui en
plus ne soit pas manipulable et bien oui
et c'est ce qu'ont découvert en 1962 les
deux mathématiciens david guez et lloyd
chapelet pour expliquer la procédure de
gueye les chapelets le plus simple est
de recourir à une analogie
imaginez que l'on ait un nombre
identique d'hommes et de femmes et qu'on
doive les mariés entre eux comme c'est
une analogie pour symboliser les
étudiants et les formations
on va chercher à faire que des mariages
hétérosexuels alors vous avez le droit
de trouver ça restrictif et on reviendra
justement sur cette hypothèse pour
appliquer la procédure inventé par gueye
les chapelets chaque personne va d'abord
classer les individus du sexe opposé par
ordre de préférence et à partir de ça on
va chercher à créer les couples voici
une illustration concrète
imaginons qu'on est trois hommes jon
jamie et drogo et trois femmes
déléris sercel et brienne voici leur
classement des individus du sexe opposé
supposons que john préfère des des
risques puis brienne et en dernier
cersei jamie préfère aussi daenerys mais
ensuite cersei puis brienne et drogo lui
préfère cersei puis daenerys et enfin
brienne et pareil pour les femmes
chacune a son classement des trois
hommes quand on essaye de faire des
couples avec ça évidemment tout le monde
n'aura pas son premier choix
il y aura des frustrés ça c'est
inévitable mais ce qu'on voudrait éviter
de créer ce sont des situations
instables où on risque d'avoir des
tentations d'adultère regardez ici on a
essayé de former les couples john
daenerys jamie cersei et drogo brienne
ça paraît pas mal hein mais regardez
drogo préféré être avec daenerys plutôt
qu'avec brienne avec qui on l'associé et
déléris de son côté préférerait aussi
être avec drogo plutôt qu'avec john dans
cette configuration deléris et drogo se
préfère mutuellement à leurs conjoints
respectifs
ils vont donc avoir envie chacun de
briser leur couple pour aller se mettre
ensemble
la configuration de mariage qu'on a créé
donc instable
la question qu'on peut se poser en
général c'est dans un problème d'union
comme celui ci avec potentiellement en
plein de participants
est-ce qu'on peut toujours trouver une
configuration stable intuitivement on
vous dit peut-être que oui ça paraît un
peu évident qui doit exister une config
a sion stable mais en fait non ça n'a
rien d'évident a priori et pour le voir
revenons sur l'hypothèse
d'hétérosexualité si on autorise tous
les couples possible aux mots comme
hétéro on change le problème cette
fois-ci tout le monde classe tout le
monde par ordre de préférence
on peut même oublié la notion de sexe et
on essaye de former des couples là
dedans et bien là il n'existe pas
toujours de configuration stable voici
un exemple très simple avec seulement
quatre personnes
claude sasha dominique et alex supposons
qu alex se soit toujours classé en
dernier par les trois autres personnes
la zone et qu'à côté on est un triangle
claude préfère sacha à dominique sacha
préfèrent dominique à claude et
dominique préfère claude à sacha mais
toujours alex an dernier est bien là
vous pouvez vous convaincre qu'il n'ya
pas de configuration stable possible
celui ou celle qui se retrouve avec alex
veut toujours se barrer et trouvera
toujours dans l'autre couple quelqu'un
qui est prêt à le rejoindre
donc dans le cas de génériques ou tous
les couples sont permis il peut donc
parfois exister des situations sans
solution stable
maintenant si on revient un autre cas où
on se limite aux couples hétéros
la question qu'on se pose c'est donc de
savoir si on peut toujours trouver au
moins une configuration de mariage
stable et dans ce cas spécifique
la réponse est oui c'est ce qu'ont
démontré en 1962 gail échapper et pour
ça ils ont fait ce qu'on appelle une
démonstration constructive ils ont
trouvé une procédure qui permet à tous
les coups de construire des mariages
stable pour expliquer cette procédure on
va continuer à filer la métaphore du
mariage on a donc des hommes des femmes
et chacun a son classement de préférence
des individus du sexe opposé
on va faire une procédure en plusieurs
tours où selon la tradition les hommes
proposent et les femmes disposent alors
voilà comment ça fonctionne
au premier tour les hommes considèrent
leur premier choix et lui font une
proposition de mariage sur notre exemple
john propose à daenerys jamie il propose
aussi à daenerys et drogo proposa cersei
ensuite chaque femme choisit son
prétendants préférés parmi ceux qui sont
proposés daenerys a le choix elle prend
dont john qu'elle préfère à jamie jamie
se retrouve donc seul cersei n'a reçu
qu'une seule proposition celle de drogo
donc elles l'acceptent et brienne n'a
rien reçu alors maintenant points
essentiels
à ce stade de la procédure les femmes
qui acceptent ne le font que de façon
provisoire
ce sont des fiançailles si vous voulez
dans l'attentes d'éventuellement trouvé
mieux à la fin de ce premier tour john
est donc fiancée à daenerys drogo
affaires cei
rihanna personnes et jamie ça fait
rejeter on fait alors un deuxième tour
où tous les hommes qui sont seuls et
uniquement eux vont proposer à leurs
choix suivant sur la liste
donc dans notre exemple il n'ya que
jamie qui soit tout seul il s'est fait
rejeter par daenerys son premier choix
donc il propose à son second choix
cersei les femmes vont alors à nouveau
choisir leurs préférés parmi leurs
prétendants en ayant le droit de rompre
leurs fiançailles
si l on quelqu'un de mieux parmi ceux
qui se proposent ici justement cersei a
reçu une proposition de jamie qu'elle
préfère à son engagement actuel avec
drogo donc elle rompt les fiançailles
prend jamie et drogo se retrouvent seuls
et on recommence ainsi de suite
autant que nécessaire à chaque tour
chaque homme seul propose à sa femme
préférée parmi celles à qui n'a pas
encore proposé et à chaque fois les
femmes disposent en rond pour leurs
fiançailles si elle trouve mieux donc
dans notre cas drogo est maintenant seul
il a déjà proposé à cersei donc il
propose à son choix suivants daenerys
daenerys est actuellement avec john mais
lui préfère dans ce cas la proposition
de drogo donc elle rejette john au tour
d'après john propose alors à son second
choix brienne qui accepte et là la
procédure se termine car tout le monde
est casé john est finalement avec
brienne jamie avec cersei et drogo avec
daenerys voici donc comment fonctionne
la procédure de mariage de gueye les
chapelets je voulais illustrer dans un
cas très simple avec seulement trois
couples mais ça se généralise à autant
que vous voulez il faut juste
éventuellement faire plus de tours
cette procédure vous trouvez peut-être
qu'elle n'a rien de révolutionnaire
c'est relativement intuitif comme façon
de faire est en effet c'est le cas mais
la principale contribution de gueule et
chapelet ça a été de montrer deux choses
tout d'abord la procédure a forcément
une fin on n'a pas des ruptures de
fiançailles à l'infini on peut démontrer
qu'au bout d'un moment ça s'arrête et
tout le monde est casé mais surtout
deuxième propriété les couples formés à
l'issue de la procédure sont stables au
sens qu'ils ne vont pas engendrer des
tentations d'adultère regardez par
exemple
jamie est avec cersei il aurait préféré
daenerys mais celle-ci lui
vers son conjoint actuel drogo donc pas
de risque d'adultère brienne et avec
john elle aurait préféré drogo ou même
jamie mais tous les deux l'ont classé
derrière leur conjoint actuel pas de
risque non plus et vous pouvez tout
vérifier comme ça ça marche
la configuration est stable puisque la
procédure de gueule chapelet peut
toujours s'impliquer et fournit
nécessairement une configuration stable
et bien ça démontre qu'il en existe
toujours une
ce qui n'était pas a priori évident
maintenant ce qu'on peut se demander
c'est si la solution qu'on a fabriqué
comme ça et la seule solution stable ou
s'il en existe d'autres
une chose que vous avez probablement
remarqué c'est que la procédure de
gueule chapelet est asymétrique
elle fait jouer un rôle différent aux
hommes et aux femmes
mais on pourrait très bien l'appliquer
dans l'autre sens un les femmes
proposent et les hommes disposent
vous pouvez vous amuser à le faire sur
mon petit d'exemple voici ce que vous
allez trouver comme couple à l'issue de
la procédure
déléris avec drogo cersei avec john et
brienne avec jamie c'est une solution
stable aussi mais pas la même que tout à
l'heure et de façon générale quand on a
beaucoup de couples il peut exister en
fait plein de solutions stables qu'elles
chapelaine en donne qu'une ou deux si
vous l'appliquez dans les deux sens mais
comparer un peu ces deux solutions
je vous représentez ici à gauche les
couples formés dans la procédure où les
femmes proposent et à droite celle où
les hommes proposent pour marquer un
truc dans notre exemple quand les femmes
proposent deux d'entre elles ont leur
premier choix et la troisième à son
second choix
pas mal tandis que chez les hommes deux
ont leurs derniers choix dans cette
configuration stable les femmes sont
carrément mieux lotis que les hommes
mais quand ce sont les hommes qui
proposent leur situation est meilleure
et celle des femmes au contraire moins
bonne
clairement avec cette procédure il
semblerait qu'il fallait mieux être dans
le groupe qui propose et ça va même plus
loin que ça gagne les chapelets ont
démontré que quand on est le groupe qui
propose on obtient la meilleure solution
qui soit parmi les solutions stables
impossible de faire mieux
malheureusement à l'opposé quand on est
le groupe qui dispose on obtient la pire
solution possible parmi les solutions
stables
alors je vous fait pas la démonstration
génériques mais intuitivement on sent
bien que si les hommes proposent ils
commencent avec leur premier choix et le
dégradent progressivement jusqu'à ce
qu'on ait une solution stable alors que
les femmes partent
ce qu'on leur propose et éventuellement
progresse au cours de la procédure
donc la méthode est complètement
inégalités entre les deux groupes elle
privilégie clairement l'un au détriment
de l'autre mais cela a un avantage
indéniable
si vous êtes dans le groupe qui propose
vous n'avez aucun intérêt à essayer de
manipuler la procédure en trichant sur
vos préférences réel par exemple pas la
peine de bidouiller de faire des savants
calculs de la jouer stratégique
de toute façon en étant sincère vous
aurez déjà la meilleure solution que
vous puissiez espérer en conclusion la
procédure de gueule chapelet a beau être
extrêmement simple
elle possède plusieurs propriétés
remarquables comme le fait d'être non
manipulable de fournir une solution
stable qui en plus est la meilleure
possible pour le groupe qui propose et
puis surtout elle va extrêmement vite
une fois qu'on dispose des classements
de préférence des unes et des autres
c'est une simple simulation des
différents tours de propositions qui se
calculent quasi instantanément sur un
ordinateur
on n'a pas besoin de redemander à chaque
fois à tout le monde quelles
propositions il fond où il accepte tout
est automatique à partir des classements
de préférence bien alors maintenant
arrêtons de parler de mariage arrangé de
façon de moyenâgeuse et revenons à nos
problèmes d'étudiants et de formation
[Musique]
pour affecter les étudiants à des
formations on peut utiliser la procédure
de gueule chapelet en disant que les
étudiants sont les hommes et les
formations les femmes et la procédure
nous permet de créer des appariements
stables entre eux dans ce contexte ça
veut dire quoi stable et bien ça veut
dire qu'il n'y aura pas de jalousie
justifier un étudiant refusé dans une
formation qui aurait à la place pris
quelqu'un de moins bien classés
souvenez-vous tout à l'heure dans notre
première procédure
bob se retrouvaient affecté à la fac de
sciences alors qu'il aurait préféré la
fac d'éco sachant que la fac d'éco avait
pris à l'iss mais aurait préféré bob à
alice bob était en situation de jalousie
justifié pour faire l'analogie avec le
mariage et l'adultère la fac d'éco et
bob préférerait aller ensemble plutôt
qu'avec leurs conjoints respectifs donc
une solution d'affectation stable c'est
une solution sans ce genre de jalousie
justifier alors justement appliquons la
procédure de gueule chapelet en
reprenant ce cas au départ
au premier tour on regarde les premiers
choix de chacun alice propose à la fac
d'éco tandis que bob et charlie propose
à la fac de lettres la fac d'éco accepte
alice provisoirement et la fac de
lettres choisies sont préférés charlie
et l'acceptent provisoirement aussi bob
est alors sans affectation à l'issue de
ce premier tour 2e tour bob est tout
seul donc il propose à son second choix
la fac d'éco comme l'affectation d'alice
en écho étaient provisoires comme des
fiançailles et que la fac d'éco préfère
justement bob et bien elle se sépare
d'alice pour le prendre
alice se retrouvent sur le carreau
troisième tour elle propose alors à son
second choix
la fac de lettres qui décident de la
prendre à la place de charlie charlie se
retrouve sans affectation quatrième tour
charles il propose à son second choix la
fac d'éco qui préfèrent regarder bob 5e
tour charlie propose alors à son
troisième choix
la fac de sciences qui l'acceptent et la
procédure se termine
alice va donc en lettres bob en écho et
charlie en sciences et là on a une
situation stable sans jalousie justifier
aucun élève ne peut se plaindre d'avoir
été refusée quelque part où on aurait
pris un candidat moins bien classé que
lui ça signifie que cette procédure
d'affectation est juste équitable grâce
à la propriété de stabilité alors deux
petites précisions concernant
l'application de cette procédure à des
situations réelles
ici on a pris un cas simples où chaque
formation n'avait qu'une seule place
mais la procédure se généralise sans
problème ou cas où chaque formation à
plusieurs places ce qui se produit
toujours en pratique est elle s'adapte
aussi aux cas où le nombre d'élèves et
le nombre total de places disponibles ne
seraient pas les mêmes dans ce cas là
bas s'il y a trop d'élèves certains
seront sans affectation à la fin et s'il
n'y en a pas assez
certaines formations ne seront pas plein
un point extrêmement important de cette
procédure on l'a dit c'est qu'elle n'est
pas manipulable dans la mesure où les
élèves obtiennent la meilleure
affectation possible parmi les
affectations stable ils n'ont aucun
intérêt à la jouer stratégique pour
tenter d'améliorer leur situation
pas de rue ou de bricolage fait
davantage à ce qui serait mieux informés
ou plus malin il suffit d'être sincère
et honnête et donc pas de stress d'avoir
fait le mauvais choix en conclusion vous
voyez que la procédure d'affectation de
gueule chapelet combine plein davantage
elle fournit une solution stable donc
équitable 1 sans jalousie justifiée elle
assure la meilleure solution pour les
étudiants du moins parmi les solutions
stables et elle n'est pas manipulable
donc pas de calcul ni de stratégie
en plus de ça elle est simple et
transparente on peut comprendre
exactement ce qui s'est passé et
pourquoi dans telle ou telle formation
on n'a pas été pris contrairement à ce
qu'on entend parfois ça n'est pas du
tout une procédure opaque une sorte dia
qui vous affecterait sens que vous
comprenez pourquoi
non non on peut parfaitement reconstitué
le raisonnement et enfin la procédure de
gueule chapelet est quasi instantané une
fois que tout le monde a fait sa liste
de préférences aussi bien les étudiants
que les formations on simule les tours
successifs de proposition dans un
ordinateur et on a très vite la réponse
pour tout le monde
sur le papier cette procédure semble
avoir quasiment tous les avantages
malgré tout il faut que je mentionne une
petite limite de cette méthode la
solution obtenue est certes la meilleure
parmi les solutions stables mais ça
n'est pas forcément la meilleure dans
l'absolu il y à des cas où on peut
trouver une solution encore meilleur en
sacrifiant la stabilité regardez mon
exemple initial avec alice bob est
charlie on l'a vu la procédure de quel
chapelet à affecter à l'iss en lettres
bob en écho et charlie en sciences
regardez spécifiquement alice et bob
alice est en lettres mais préfèrerait
l'écho bob est en écho mais préfèrerait
lettre eh bien ils n'ont qu'à échanger
leur place
si on fait ça la solution qu'on obtient
être encore meilleur elle donne plus de
satisfaction à alice et bob et ne
dégrade pas la situation de charlie mais
elle pose un problème
charlie se retrouve alors en situation
de jalousie justifié il peut
légitimement se plaindre que bob soit
pris en lettres alors que lui charlie se
trouvaient beaucoup mieux classés que
lui on a trouvé une solution meilleure
mais instable donc inéquitable ce petit
exemple illustre un des paradoxes de ces
questions d'affectation la meilleure
solution possible n'est pas forcément
stable et donc pas forcément juste en
utilisant la procédure de gueule
chapelet ont choisi de privilégier la
stabilité et donc l'équité de la
procédure
on pourrait utiliser une autre méthode
qui privilégie le fait de trouver la
meilleure solution en sacrifiant
l'équité si nécessaire ça existe ça
s'appelle la procédure du cycle des
changes optimale elle a été imaginée
aussi par david guez et on utilise
notamment pour des questions
d'affectation dans le cas du don
d'organes
cette procédure sacrifie l'équité au
profit de l'optimalité mais entre ça et
qu'elle chapelet il n'existe pas de
procédure qui permette d'avoir à la fois
l'un et l'autre il faut faire un choix
on la digue et le chapelet trouve la
meilleure solution parmi les solutions
stables qui est déjà remarquable et
c'est ce qui explique que c'est plus ou
moins cette procédure qui est utilisé
dans de nombreux pays qui pratiquent une
affectation centralisée des choix par
exemple les internes en médecine aux
états unis dont on a parlé ou encore les
études supérieures en allemagne en
italie en turquie en tunisie au chili
etc et bien évidemment c'est aussi cette
procédure qui est à l'origine de la
méthode utilisée en france entre 2009 et
2010 est la procédure apb pour admission
postbac
[Musique]
dans la procédure apb tout commence par
le classement que les étudiants
établissent ils choisissent au maximum
24 formations qui les intéressent et les
classe par ordre de préférence
l'idée d'apb et d'appliquer une
procédure de geisha play c'est à dire un
calcul ou à partir de ces listes de
préférence on calcule automatiquement
une solution stable pour que la
procédure puisse s'appliquer il faut
donc aussi évidemment que les formations
classe les étudiants et c'est là que ça
se complique il y a en france deux
grands types de formations post bac
d'un côté les formations dites sélective
comme les bts classes prépas iut qui
traditionnellement classe et
sélectionnent leurs candidats selon des
critères qui leur sont propres
c'est une grosse moitié de l'offre de
formation et de l'autre on a les
licences universitaires qui sont des
formations dites non sélective
c'est à dire qu'elles n'ont légalement
pas le droit de sélectionner leurs
étudiants
du moins pas sur des critères scolaires
historiquement c'est l'article 14 de la
loi du 26 janvier 1984 le premier cycle
est ouvert à tous les titulaires du
baccalauréat
tout candidat est libre de s'inscrire
dans l'établissement de son choix
les dispositions relatives à la
répartition entre les établissements et
les formations exclut toute sélection
donc en france à partir du moment où on
a le bac on a accès à l'enseignement
universitaire et donc le droit de
s'inscrire en licence
peu importe nos notes notre filière
d'origine la sélection est interdite
pour beaucoup de licences universitaires
ça ne pose pas de problème particulier
car le nombre de places est suffisant
pour accueillir toutes celles et ceux
qu'ils souhaitent
mais pour certaines filières très
demandés comme le droit la psycho les
études de santé ou encore staps du fait
que chaque étudiant peut proposer 24
choix dans apb
on se retrouve avec plus de candidats
que de places disponibles
on dit que ces licences sont en tension
est donc d'une façon ou d'une autre ces
licences universitaires doivent trouver
un moyen de classer les étudiants afin
qu'on puisse appliquer la procédure de
galles chapelet sauf qu'ils n'ont pas le
droit de le faire
en tout cas pas sur des critères
scolaires pour résoudre ce problème des
licences en tension apb avaient recours
automatiquement à trois critères
successifs premièrement on regarde
l'académie d'origine et on donne
priorité aux étudiants locaux on peut
discuter l'idée mais elle n'est pas
forcément absurde
pourquoi pas ensuite pour départager les
étudiants de la même académie on regarde
en quelle position ils ont classé cette
formation dans leurs voeux l'idée
derrière c'est que mettez-vous à la
place d'une de ces formations disons
staps vous avez le choix entre quelqu'un
qui a classé staps en premier choix est
quelqu'un qui l'a classé en troisième
choix
eh bien vous avez envie de donner
priorité à celui qui la classait en
premier on favorise ceux qui veulent
vraiment cette formation ça paraît assez
naturel est relativement juste dit comme
ça mais en fait c'est une entorse énorme
au principe de geisha plaît et ça pose
de gros problèmes à apb en principe dans
la procédure de gueule chapelet tout le
monde établit son classement de façon
honnête et objective sans tenir compte
de ce que font les autres
or quand pour une licence en tension on
utilise les critères que je viens
d'exposer
c'est comme si chaque formation
attendait d'avoir le classement des
étudiants pour établir le sien en
fonction et favoriser les étudiants qui
l'ont classé en premier donc on seront
la logique de la procédure de gueule
chapelet et le souci que ça pose c'est
que ça la rend manipulable imaginez que
votre classement sincère ce soit disons
classe prépa en premier et en 2 staps
mais que vous sachiez qu'il ya un risque
de ne pas être pris en prépa en principe
avec la procédure de get chapelet vous
pouvez sans risque être sincère et
donner ce classement la prépa puis staps
mais avec un système comme un pb il ya
un risque que d'abord la prépa vous
refuse et ensuite que staps vous refuse
aussi car vous ne l'avez pas classé en
premier et donc vous êtes complètement
perdre ce qu'il faudrait faire dans le
doute c'est faire une croix sur la prépa
sans jamais savoir si vous auriez vos
chances maîtres staps en premier pour
assurer le coup donc on se retrouve avec
les défauts du tout premier système que
j'avais présenté pour réussir il faut
jouer tactique et mentir dans son
classement sans savoir si on a fait le
bon calcul
ce qui est quand même un peu stressant
et favorise ceux qui connaissent le
mieux le système et c'est d'autant plus
grave
cap et bep un site est justement à être
sincère en disant dans son guide je cite
vous pouvez modifier le classement de
vos demandes de formation par ordre de
préférence et sans autocensure et bien
non si vous suiviez ce conseil il y
avait un certain risque de se faire
avoir
ça c'est le premier gros problème d'apb
deuxième problème même en prenant en
compte cette manière de
partager il reste encore parfois des
ex-aequo pour certaines licences très
demandée est là pour sélectionner la
procédure apb avaient recours tout
simplement à un tirage au sort en 2017
ça s'est produit pour une centaine de
licences et le tirage au sort a concerné
près de soixante mille candidats un
exemple parmi d'autres cette année là il
y avait en ile-de-france pour la paces
l'ex première année de médecine 8507
candidats ayant tous classés cette
formation en choix numéro un ils étaient
donc tous ex-aequo mais il n'y avait que
sept mille six cent cinquante places
il a donc fallu tirer au sort pour
éliminer 857 étudiants chaque étudiant
avait donc en gros une chance sur 10 de
se faire refuser et ce indépendamment de
tout critère pédagogique
finalement ça fait scandale on a trouvé
une solution au dernier moment pour
admettre tout le monde mais cela a
précipité la chute d'apb et la mise en
place en 2018 une nouvelle plateforme
parcouru
[Musique]
le fonctionnement de parcours sucre est
dans les grandes lignes identique à
celui d'appeller mais avec plusieurs
changements importants
tout d'abord plus de tirage au sort et
pour cela toutes les formations
reçoivent elle même le droit de classer
les candidats sur des critères scolaires
y compris les licences universitaires en
tensions qui peuvent de fait
sélectionner leurs étudiants sur la base
de leurs notes de leurs filières etc
autre changement important
cette fois les formations ne peuvent
plus utiliser les classements fait par
les candidats pour favoriser ce qui
aurait classé la formation au premier
rang comme c'était le cas dans apb
et si ça ça n'est plus possible c'est
tout simplement parce que les candidats
ne classe plus leur choix il faut une
liste de voeux des formations qui les
intéressent mais ils ne font pas de
classement de hiérarchisation
à première vue c'est plutôt avantageux
pour les étudiants ça leur laisse le
temps de la réflexion de mûrir leur
projet d'orientation
ils ne doivent plus dès le départ décidé
de classer toutes les formations ce qui
n'est pas forcément si évident plusieurs
mois avant la rentrée et sans savoir
s'ils ont leur chance
donc la suppression de cette
hiérarchisation des voeux par les
candidats ça paraît plutôt une bonne
chose
sauf que ça pose un gros problème de
fonctionnement de la procédure avec apb
on avait toutes les préférences dès le
départ donc on pouvait calculer les
affectations en simulant avec un
ordinateur les différents tours de
propositions de la procédure de gueule
chapelet et ça allait très vite un
seulement quelques minutes de calcul
avec pas pour sup
les candidats ne classe plus d' avance
et donc voici ce qui se passe les
étudiants ont fait leurs voeux sans
classement les formations reçoivent la
liste des étudiants qui les ont choisis
et doivent les classer entre eux en
fonction de ça les formations renvoie
aux étudiants une réponse ça peut être
oui
dans ce cas ils sont admis s'ils le
souhaitent en attente
ils sont sur les attentes bien non six
ont fusé lors cette dernière possibilité
c'est uniquement pour les formations
sélectives dans une licence
universitaire même si vous êtes classé
dernier
vous serez sur liste d'attenté les
étudiants doivent alors impérativement
donner une réponse aux formations qui
leur ont dit oui
ils ont quelques jours pour le faire
l'idée c'est comme les fiançailles c'est
d'accepter la formation qu'on préfère
parmi celles qui nous ont répondu
favorablement et donc refusé les autres
pour libérer les places
c'est donc seulement à ce moment là que
les étudiants doivent réfléchir à la
hiérarchisation de leurs voeux et
uniquement entre les réponses positives
ce qui est plus facile et évidemment si
on dit oui à une formation c'est comme
les fiançailles c'est provisoire
ça ne nous empêche pas d'accepter plus
tard une autre formation qui nous
auraient initialement mis sur liste
d'attenté comme des places se libèrent
une fois que les candidats ont répondu
un deuxième tour s'enclenche et les
formations peuvent refaire des
propositions donc dire oui à certains de
ceux qui étaient sur liste d'attenté et
on recommence les formations proposent
et à chaque fois les étudiants doivent
réfléchir pour répondre à force d'aller
retour en principe ça finira par
converger vers une solution stable donc
ce qu'il se passe en pratique avec ce
système c'est qu'au lieu de résoudre
tout d'un coup dans un ordinateur on se
retrouve à reproduire grandeur nature à
la main les différents tours de
propositions de la procédure de galles
chapelet alors premières observations
vous l'aurez peut-être noté dans cette
procédure
les formations proposent et les élèves
disposent vous souvenez de ce que ça
signifie
la procédure convergent vers la
meilleure solution possible pour ceux
qui propose donc ici les formations est
par contre pour ceux qui disposent ici
les élèves on obtient la pire solution
possible parmi les solutions stables
en bref on favorise les formations au
détriment des élèves
on savait peut-être pas si grave car il
semblerait qu'en pratique il n'y est pas
tant de différences que ça entre les
deux solutions
mais sur le principe c'est un peu
choquant enfin c'est pas le pire le
principal souci avec parcours super
c'est que chaque aller-retour peut
prendre presque une semaine et donc pour
arriver au bout de la procédure et que
chacun reçoive son affectation ça dure
des mois à comparer aux quelques minutes
que prenait le calcul d'apb et oui par
cap et bep souvenez vous on avait d'
avance le classement des voeux des
candidats
là on redemande à chaque fois à tous les
étudiants ce qu'ils préfèrent pour
choisir parmi les réponses positives
évidemment toute cette attente qui dure
des mois génère beaucoup de stress pour
les étudiants qui doivent sans cesse
consulter la plateforme pour voir si
leur situation bouge s'ils ont reçu de
nouvelles propositions
à tel point que l'accès à parcours sup
est complètement bloquée pendant les
épreuves du bac pour éviter de trop
perturber les élèves de terminale alors
oui en théorie le fait de ne pas
hiérarchiser les voeux donne beaucoup
plus de libé
et aux étudiants pour mûrir leur projet
mais il faut pas se leurrer non plus on
sait très bien qu'en pratique beaucoup
d'étudiants finiront par craquer et
abandonné c'est à dire qu'ils
accepteront définitivement une formation
qui n'auraient pas été leur premier
choix
par lassitude d'être sur listes
d'attentes et d'être dans le stress et
l'incertitude de ne pas savoir ce qu'ils
vont devenir
finalement on a un peu l'impression
d'être revenu au procédure décentralisée
qui existait avant même apb et qui était
longue et stressante et inégalitaire à
part la lenteur on peut mentionner un
autre défaut de parcours sup
le fait qu'il n'y ait plus de
hiérarchisation des voeux limite
grandement la possibilité de faire des
statistiques avec un système comme abb
on pouvait estimer à la fin quel
pourcentage des étudiants avaient eu
leur premier choix ou combien il aurait
fallu deux places dans chaque formation
pour que tout le monde soit content avec
parcours super on ne connaît jamais ce
qui aurait été le premier choix des
étudiants
donc on perd un outil d'évaluation du
fonctionnement du système alors avec
tout ce que je viens de dire on peut se
demander légitimement pourquoi cette
apparente régression lié au fait de ne
plus y archi zélés veut et bien il y as
je crois plusieurs bonnes raisons et une
mauvaise parmi les bonnes on l'a vu il y
a le fait de donner plus de temps aux
étudiants pour réfléchir bon ok autre
avantage indéniable de cette non
hiérarchisation
c'est le nouveau dispositif appelé oui
si qui permet aux formations d'accepter
une étudiante ou un étudiant sous
réserve qu'ils ou elles suivent une
formation complémentaire
et ça ce serait compliqué à prendre en
compte dès le départ avec une
hiérarchisation parce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'un élève soit très
intéressés par une formation mais
beaucoup moins intéressé si par exemple
celle suit lui demande un rattrapage
préalable et enfin dernière innovation
positif de parcours sup c'est le fait
pour les formations de pouvoir prendre
en compte un quota minimum de boursiers
et un quota maximum d'étudiants hors
académie et la prise en compte de ces
quotas se fait de façon automatique à
partir des classements établis par les
formations grâce à l'algorithme conçu
par les chercheurs clerc mathieu et ugo
humbert
au total je ne sais pas si ces avantages
justifient le stress supplémentaire
engendrée par la non utilisation des
voeux mais je crois surtout que derrière
les spécifications de parcours sup
il y a aussi une mauvaise raisons plus
politiques une des choses qui a
notamment sonner le glas d'apb c'est un
avis rendu en 2017 par la cnil la
commission nationale informatique
berthet cet avis concerne est
spécifiquement apb et il a interdit le
recours au tirage au sort ce qu'on peut
largement comprendre mais il a aussi
imposé une intervention humaine dans le
traitement des dossiers en interdisant
une affectation purement basée sur
l'emploi d'algorithmes alors je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que les gens de
la cnil sache très bien de quoi il parle
mais cet avis a été utilisé pour
enterrer apb en accusant ainsi les
algorithmes et cela relève me
semble-t-il surtout d'une entourloupe et
d'une confusion on l'a vu il y avait de
vrais problèmes avec apb
mais la méthode de base la procédure de
gueule chapelet est parfaitement
efficace et adaptée pour peu qu'on
l'appliqué correctement alors oui cette
procédure est ce qu'on peut appeler un
algorithme même si vous noterez que j'ai
fait exprès d'éviter ce mot si les
étudiants et les formations ont
renseigné leur classement correctement
alors on a un gros calculs informatiques
qui se fait de façon automatique et
fournit en sortie la liste des
affectations en quelques minutes c'est
un algorithme qui tourne sur un
ordinateur mais la procédure est
parfaitement connue transparente et
explicable à n'importe quel élève de
terminale en tout cas j'espère avoir
réussi à le faire et en principe chacun
devrait pouvoir vérifier et comprendre
le pourquoi de son affectation
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu entendre
apb n'était pas un algorithme opaque
boîtes noires une sorte d'intelligence
artificielle qui déciderait pour vous de
votre avenir sans que vous n'y comprenez
rien d'ailleurs à la fin avec parcours
sup on a reproduit presque exactement la
même procédure d'affectation kbb le même
algorithme mais avec plein d'allers
retours entre les étudiants et les
formations au lieu d'un truc automatique
conséquence ça prend des mois mais ce
délai est presque totalement
artificielle a comme effet secondaire de
rassurer les gens en enlevant cette
impression qu un ordinateur central
décide en quelques secondes pour tout le
monde
on donne l'impression de rendre du libre
arbitre d'ailleurs voici ce que disait
un responsable du ministère dans une
interview au blog ingénue ingénieurs
l'idée avec parcours sud c'était de
mettre en place un nouveau système fondé
sur la transparence et la liberté de
choix pour les candidats avec apb
c'était les algorithmes qui faisait la
loi
quand on lit ça on a vraiment
l'impression car pb c'était de la magie
noire alors que je le répète le principe
d'affectation et est essentiellement le
même qu'avec parcours sup mais à
avec parcours su c'est très très
ralentie en gros un des bénéfices de
cette procédure super lente c'est
d'enlever cette impression qu'un
algorithme décide pour vous de votre
avenir
même si le résultat final est presque le
même et je pense que c'était clairement
l'intention
évidemment en tant que vulgarisateur
scientifique ça me frustre de voir qu'on
se retrouve dans cette situation tendue
parce qu'on n'a pas été capable
d'expliquer comment marche la procédure
ce qu'est un algorithme et pourquoi
algorithmes et bien c'est pas synonyme
d'un truc démoniaque et arbitraire
d'ailleurs pour bien poser le débat il
est probablement utile de faire une
distinction importante entre les
algorithmes d'appariement et ceux de
classement des étudiants dans apb
l'algorithme d'appariement c'était
qu'elle chapelet qui marche très bien on
l'a vu et l'algorithme de classement
pour les 800 sans tensions s'étaient
cette suite de critères academy
d'origine rendu veut et enfin tirage au
sort on voit bien que ce qui n'allait
pas du tout c'était la partie classement
la procédure d'appariement marchait très
bien
or le passage à parcours suez a modifié
les deux il a remplacé la partie
classement par une vraie procédure de
sélection basés sur des critères
pédagogiques avec une intervention
humaine ce qui va plutôt dans le bon
sens même si ça manque encore de
transparence sur les critères et en ce
qui concerne la procédure d'appariement
parcours super à garder essentiellement
la même chose qu'à pb mais super ralenti
du fait qu'il n'ya plus de
hiérarchisation des voeux et ça ça n'est
pas du tout la faute de ceux qui ont
conçu l'algorithme le fait de ne plus
hiérarchisé les voeux et est une
spécification très claire du ministère
et franchement on peut se demander si
les bénéfices justifiées à ce choix
une façon de faire qui permettrait de
retenir les avantages de la non
hiérarchisée à sion tout en évitant trop
d'attentes et de stress ce serait de
limiter la période pendant laquelle les
candidats ne classe pas les voeux ça n'a
rien d'extraordinaire assez par exemple
exactement ce qui se passe en allemagne
avec la procédure d eau s v les
étudiants font une liste de voeux sans
classement
les formations répondent et au bout d'un
délai de 1 mois
les étudiants sont obligés de faire une
hiérarchisation donc on sait qu'au bout
d'un mois d'attentes maximum la
hiérarchisation des voeux permettra un
traitement automatique accéléré et le
système convergera et proposera
rapidement d affectation définitive
ça permet aussi de s'assurer que le
moins de gens possible vont
restés sur le carreau alors qu'avec le
système actuel en france on peut se
retrouver à rappeler des gens à la fin
de l'été parce qu'une place est
finalement libéré et c'est bien sûr je
ne dis pas qu'il faille sabordé par
coups reçus pour tout reprendre à zéro
mais on peut espérer qu'au fil des
années des améliorations de ce type
seront ajoutés pour rendre le système
plus juste plus transparent et plus
efficace
voilà c'est tout pour cette vidéo qui
vous aura un peu changé de la science
pure et dure
comme toujours il y à pas mal de détails
de complément et de source dans le
billet de blog qui accompagne la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à les lire
si vous avez aimé la vidéo n'oubliez pas
de mettre un pouce vous abonner la
cloche tout ça les actus de la chaîne ça
se passe sur facebook et twitter et on
se retrouve prochainement pour une
nouvelle vidéo
à bientôt
[Musique]